From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台，节目是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
OK. Let me catch you up. If you didn't hear last week's show, we are picking up that story this week. And if you didn't hear it, I can bring you up to speed very quickly.
好了。让我来帮你补补课。如果你没听上周的节目，我们这周会继续讲述那个故事。如果你没听过，我可以很快让你了解大概。
OK, there's a couple, the Mathises, Rob and Reyna, and they're looking for a house. And they tour a pretty nice one. But then they see some Confederate flags in the downstairs rooms. They go upstairs, and in a bedroom, there's something in a picture frame on the wall.
事情是这样的，有一对夫妇，马西斯夫妇——罗伯和雷娜，他们正在找房子。他们参观了一间相当不错的房子。但随后他们在楼下的房间里看到了一些邦联旗。他们上楼，在一个卧室里，墙上的相框里有样东西。
So I look up at the picture, and I lean in and look at it. I'm like, are you kidding me? This is a KKK application.
我抬头看着那张照片，凑近看了看。我在想，你是在开玩笑吗？这是一份三K党的申请表。
All of a sudden, I hear him cussing and coming down the stairs. And he's like, we gotta go now.
突然，我听到他在楼梯上骂骂咧咧地走下来。他说，我们现在得走了。
Turns out the house and the Confederate flags and the KKK application were owned by a police officer named Charles Anderson. He was on the police force in their town, Muskegon, Michigan, which is a town of 38,000 on the Western side of Michigan Lake, right on the lake.
原来，那房子、邦联旗和三K党申请表的主人是一名名叫查尔斯·安德森的警察。他在密歇根州马斯基根市的警局工作，那是一个位于密歇根湖西岸的小镇，人口有 3.8 万。
The Mathises decide they're going to go public with this discovery, mostly because Rob thinks if someday this officer pulls over a Black couple and does something horrible, he doesn't want to wish that he had said something. He wants to warn people. Rob, by the way, is Black. Reyna is Mexican-American. Officer Anderson is white.
马西斯夫妇决定公开这一发现，主要是因为罗伯认为，如果有一天这名警察拦住了一对黑人夫妇并做了什么可怕的事，他不想让自己事后后悔当时没站出来。他想提醒大家。顺便提一下，罗伯是黑人，雷娜是墨西哥裔美国人，安德森警官是白人。
So they post about it on Facebook, and it blows up. People come forward. They say they've had troubling run-ins with this officer in the past. Officer Anderson is suspended while the police department investigates.
于是他们在 Facebook 上发布了这件事，结果引发了轰动。人们纷纷站出来，说过去曾与这名警察有过令人不安的冲突。安德森警官在警察局调查期间被停职。
OK, so last time on our show, Ben Calhoun, one of our editors and producers here, told the story of the Mathises. And we heard the testimony that Officer Anderson gave to police investigators about the whole thing. And we heard from Anderson's wife about how and why they got that KKK application.
好了，上期节目中，我们的编辑兼制作人本·卡尔霍恩讲述了马西斯夫妇的故事。我们听取了安德森警官对调查人员所作的证词，也听了安德森妻子的讲述，了解他们为何会有那份三K党申请表。
We also heard from a former pastor named Duke Stalling, who told a story about what Officer Anderson could be like as a cop, how Anderson showed up at his mother's 59th birthday party and ended up pepper spraying a bunch of his older relatives.
我们还采访了一位前牧师杜克·斯托林，他讲述了安德森警官作为警察时的表现——他曾出现在他母亲 59 岁的生日派对上，最后竟对一群年长的亲戚使用了胡椒喷雾。
Some people fought. Some-- I can't see. You hear a bunch of screaming and trying to run. They were not causing any harm to him at all. Like, nobody's crazy enough to hit a police. My family, we're not crazy. Nobody's going to put their hands on a police officer or anything like that.
有些人反抗了。有些人——我看不到。你听到一阵尖叫和逃跑的声音。他们根本没有对他造成任何伤害。毕竟，没人会疯狂到去袭击警察。我的家人，我们并不疯狂。没人会对手上戴着警徽的人动粗。
Today, Ben turns to the story of the city's investigation into Officer Anderson, which played out in a strange and surprising way that had serious consequences for the Mathises. Ben starts with Act 1, Chief Lewis Adds It Up. Here's Ben.
今天，本将深入讲述马斯基根市对安德森警官的调查，这件事的发展既奇怪又出人意料，并给马西斯夫妇带来了严重的影响。本先从第一幕讲起，《刘易斯局长算总账》。有请本。
So there was the official investigation into Officer Anderson by the Muskegon Police Department's internal affairs team. As you might have heard last week, that investigation went kind of soft on him. The investigator literally invited Anderson to, quote, "explain away the situation."
当时马斯基根警察局的内务部门对安德森警官进行了正式调查。正如你们上周可能听到的，那次调查对他相当包庇。调查人员甚至直接邀请安德森“解释一下情况”。
But while that investigation was unfolding, the police chief, Jeff Lewis, was taking his own look at Anderson, a harder, more critical look. It turned out Lewis had questions about Anderson before any of this happened. In fact, a year before the Mathises' post, a video had popped up online that made Lewis worried about Anderson.
但在调查进行期间，警察局长杰夫·刘易斯也在从自己的角度审视安德森，进行了一次更深入、更严厉的审查。原来，在这件事发生之前，刘易斯就对安德森有所质疑。事实上，在马西斯夫妇发布消息的一年前，网上就出现了一段视频，让刘易斯对安德森感到担忧。
We watched this together. It was a cell phone video taken at night with a woman being pushed into the back of a Muskegon police car. Anderson is standing behind the officer doing the pushing. And then you see two women walk up, one younger and then an elderly woman right next to her, both Black, like everyone in the video but Anderson.
我们一起观看了这段视频。这是晚上拍摄的手机视频，一名女性被推入马斯基根警车的后座。安德森站在推人的警察身后。随后你可以看到两名女性走过来，一个较年轻，旁边还有一位年长的女性，都是黑人，就像视频里除了安德森以外的所有人一样。
So Anderson turns, and he sees the women.
安德森转过身，看到了她们。
I'm sure he has his side of the story. But as you can see, he spins around and just, without even trying to verbally de-escalate or do anything, he just shoves this elderly woman to the ground, which is just inappropriate. It is wrong. It's just out of bounds, period.
我相信他有自己的说法。但正如你所见，他转过身，甚至没有试图进行语言上的降温或做任何处理，直接就把那位老妇人推倒在地，这显然是不合适的。这是错的。这完全越界了。
Why you just knee that lady right there? Hey, you pushed that old lady. You should be ashamed of yourself.
你凭什么膝撞那位女士？嘿，你推倒了那位老太太。你应该为自己感到羞耻。
I just can't justify that. I just can't, anyway I look at it. I can't even say he was technically right because I don't remember ever throwing down a grandmother in my career. I just didn't feel like throwing a grandma down.
我无法为那种行为辩解。无论怎么看都无法辩解。我甚至不能说他在技术层面上是对的，因为我不记得我的职业生涯中曾经把哪位祖母推倒在地。我只是觉得没必要把一位老太太推倒。
A complaint was filed about this incident and Lewis took note. He was concerned that Anderson was kind of a cowboy and aggressive. Then, the very same week the Mathises posted, he heard another story about Anderson.
针对这次事件有人提出了投诉，刘易斯注意到了。他担心安德森这种牛仔式的作风太过激进。然后，就在马西斯夫妇发帖的同一周，他又听到了关于安德森的另一个故事。
A Black business owner he knew told him about a disturbing run-in she'd had with him, that he'd been rude and aggressive and told her to shut up. Then once all this started to blow up, Lewis says some officers started to come to him discreetly and tell him they had concerns about Anderson, which prompted him to tally up everything he knew about Anderson.
一位他认识的黑人女企业家告诉了他一次令人不安的经历，安德森当时粗鲁且咄咄逼人，还叫她闭嘴。然后，当这件事开始爆发时，刘易斯说一些警察开始私下向他表达对安德森的担忧，这促使他盘点了关于安德森的所有已知情况。
There's the Julius Johnson shooting. I talked about last time, where Anderson killed an unarmed Black man. That was before Lewis arrived in Muskegon, and Anderson was officially cleared of any wrongdoing. But Lewis questioned Anderson's judgment and the decisions that he made that led to the shooting. He added, on top of that, two other shootings Anderson was involved in, in addition to Julius Johnson.
比如朱利叶斯·约翰逊枪击案。我上次提到过，安德森打死了一名手无寸铁的黑人男子。那是在刘易斯来到马斯基根之前发生的，安德森正式被判定无罪。但刘易斯质疑安德森的判断力以及导致那次枪击的决定。此外，他还补充了安德森除朱利叶斯·约翰逊案外还卷入的两起枪击案。
If you look at the national average-- I've been a police officer for 40 years and involved in no shootings. The vast majority of police officers go through their career and never shoot anyone. I don't think the public knows that.
如果你看全国平均水平——我当了 40 年警察，一次枪击事件都没卷入过。绝大多数警察职业生涯中从未开枪打过任何人。我不认为公众知道这一点。
Nobody keeps national statistics on the percentage of officers that shoot people. A Pew study says only 27% of police officers have even fired their guns, but that includes warning shots and shooting animals, anything else. One expert told us the number of police who have actually shot and killed someone is almost certainly less than 1%.
没有人保存过关于警察枪杀平民比例的全国统计数据。皮尤研究中心的一项调查称，只有 27% 的警察曾开过枪，但这包括鸣枪示警、射杀动物等情况。一位专家告诉我们，真正开枪打死过人的警察比例几乎肯定不到 1%。
I couldn't even find a statistic or a department like this, and you're involved in three shootings.
我甚至找不到像这样的统计数据或部门，而你竟然卷入了三起枪击案。
You think he was an outlier in that way?
你认为他在那方面是个异类吗？
Yeah. I mean, either you have the worst luck or something's going on here. And then when you looked at his history, there was a progressive, I guess, glaring performance with him when it came to dealing with African-Americans especially. In other words, he seemed to have a lot of problems with African-Americans through his career.
是的。我是说，要么你运气最差，要么就是有什么猫腻。当你审视他的历史时，你会发现他在处理非裔美国人问题上，确实表现出一种令人震惊的倾向。换句话说，他在整个职业生涯中似乎与非裔美国人有很多矛盾。
Lewis said Anderson would have these kind of problematic interactions with Black people. But over and over again, he'd be cleared, found to be within the bounds of department policy.
刘易斯说，安德森常有这类与黑人的冲突。但一次又一次，他都被判无罪，被认为是在警局政策范围之内。
His whole career, things would happen and he would kind of come out the other side. And I'm not sure why. I mean, you'd have to go back and look at every incident.
他的整个职业生涯里，事情总会发生，而他总能全身而退。我不确定为什么。我是说，你得回去翻看每一件事故。
I've had officers get in car accidents. And let's say you have an officer in five car accidents, and none was his fault. As a chief, you go, OK, it appears it's not your fault. But why are you in five not-at-fault accidents, when the other 99% of the officers aren't having this?
我的下属发生过车祸。假设一名警察发生了五次车祸，且都不是他的错。作为局长，你会说，好吧，看来不是你的错。但为什么你在五次车祸中都“无责”，而其他 99% 的警察都没遇到这种情况？
What are you doing that you keep getting in accidents and you're not at fault? We got a big pile of cars you wrecked, but you're never at fault. Chuck is one of those kind of things where, when I looked at his past, there's good things in there. I'm not going to take that away from him.
你到底在干什么导致你不断卷入车祸且“无责”？我们有一大堆你撞坏的车，但你从未有过错。查克就是那种情况，当我回顾他的过去时，里面确实有好的方面。我不会抹杀他的功劳。
I started seeing a pattern that he just wasn't effective with our African-American citizens. He just wasn't. So what are you going to do?
我开始看出一种模式，他就是无法有效地与我们的非裔美国公民相处。他就是做不到。那么，你能怎么办？
Lewis says he knew pretty quickly what he was going to do. He wanted to fire Anderson, partly on principle. 2 plus 2 is 4, he told me. Anderson has a problem with Black people. There was no doubt in my mind.
刘易斯说他很快就知道该怎么做了。他想解雇安德森，部分是出于原则。他告诉我，2 加 2 等于 4。安德森和黑人有问题。我心里毫无疑问。
But also, on top of that, lots of people were telling Lewis he had no choice. He had to get rid of this officer. The city's social justice committee, the city's vice mayor-- who's also the president of the local NAACP-- everyone was saying if Anderson stayed, there'd be backlash, protests, hostility. And not just towards Anderson, but towards everyone on the force.
但除此之外，很多人都在告诉刘易斯他别无选择。他必须除掉这名警察。市里的社会公正委员会、副市长——他同时也是当地全国有色人种协进会（NAACP）的主席——所有人都说，如果安德森留下来，就会有抵制、抗议和敌意。这不仅是针对安德森，也是针对警局里的所有人。
It's going to endanger him and my other 79 officers. And matter of fact, I'm not going to be part of this agency if that's how we're going to be. I said, I cannot, in good conscience, bring him back here and put him back on the streets of this town.
这会危及他和我其他 79 名警察的安全。事实上，如果我们要变成那样，我就不干这个局长了。我说，凭良心讲，我不能让他回到这个城市的大街上巡逻。
So at this point in our story, you've got a town where lots of people think a police officer has a problem with Black people. The white police chief looks into it and agrees. It seems like a clear-cut case. Fire the officer, call out his bad behavior, apologize to the public.
所以，在我们的故事进展到这里时，你所面对的是一个城市，很多人认为一名警察对黑人有偏见。白人警察局长调查后也表示同意。这似乎是一个非常明确的案件。解雇这名警察，谴责他的恶劣行为，并向公众道歉。
And yet, that is not what ends up happening. Which brings us to Act 2, The Way it Actually Happened.
然而，结果并非如此。这就引出了第二幕，《事情的真相》。
Now to the breaking news out of Muskegon, where a police officer who had Ku Klux Klan memorabilia in his home has been fired.
现在插播马斯基根的突发新闻，一名家中藏有三K党纪念品的警察已被解雇。
When the news hit that Chief Lewis did what he said and fired officer Anderson, there was no explanation why he was fired. The closest they got to that came 11 days later, when the city released their official report on Anderson, the result of the investigation Chief Lewis ordered.
当刘易斯局长真的如他所言解雇了安德森警官的消息传出时，并没有给出解雇原因的解释。最接近真相的说明出现在 11 天后，当时市政府发布了关于安德森的官方报告，这是刘易斯局长下令进行的调查结果。
This report, it's one of the reasons I got interested in this. It's over 400 pages, so it seems like it's going to be kind of a reckoning of the kind of officer Anderson had been during his two decades on the Muskegon police force and include all the incidents you've heard about, settle some big questions about the kind of officer he was. But the report was nothing like that.
这份报告是我感兴趣的原因之一。它有 400 多页长，看起来就像是对安德森在马斯基根警察局二十年警察生涯的一种清算，包含了你们听到的所有事件，并解决关于他是什么样警察的大问题。但这份报告完全不是那回事。
The report almost entirely portrays Officer Anderson as, well, a pretty great police officer. It's hundreds of pages clearing him of wrongdoing and showcasing things he'd done well in his career. It was so much so that, the first time I read it, I didn't even understand how this was used as justification for Anderson being fired.
报告几乎完全将安德森描述为一名非常出色的警察。有数百页的内容在证明他无罪，并展示了他职业生涯中的成就。以至于我第一次读的时候，甚至不明白为什么这能作为解雇安德森的理由。
So much of what had come up and what people were talking about wasn't even addressed. Like, there's an analysis of Anderson's traffic stop, showing it did not appear he was targeting non-white drivers. There's a big section about his commendations.
很多引发争议和公众讨论的问题甚至都没有涉及。比如，有一份针对安德森交通拦截的分析，显示他似乎并没有专门针对非白人司机。还有一大块关于他所获表彰的内容。
There's 10 interviews with officers, white and non-white, talking about how they think Anderson's fair and a good officer, and they wish he could come back to work. Some seem boilerplate, but others seem heartfelt.
报告中有 10 次对白人和非白人警察的采访，他们谈到认为安德森是个公平且优秀的警察，希望他能回来工作。有些话看起来像是套话，但有些听起来很真诚。
One Black officer, without prompting, talks about how Anderson has gone out of his way to help him at work and been a guest at his house. "He's been to your house?" the investigator asks. "He has," says the Black officer. "He helped me put a roof on my house, and his father and wife spent the whole day at my house."
一位黑人警察未经提醒就谈到安德森在工作中对他有多么关照，还曾是家里的座上宾。“他去过你家？”调查员问道。“是的，”这名黑人警察说。“他帮我修过屋顶，他父亲和妻子在我家待了一整天。”
So many of the things the chief found so disturbing that convinced him Anderson had a problem with Black people, they just weren't in there. Like the video of him pushing the old woman onto the ground, or Lewis' concerns about the number of people Anderson shot. The only interview where anyone says anything negative about Anderson is the interview with the Mathises, and they only talk about the flags and the KKK application.
局长发现的那些令人不安、认为安德森对黑人有偏见的证据，在报告里根本没提到。比如他把老妇人推倒在地的视频，或者刘易斯关于安德森卷入多次枪击案的担忧。唯一提及安德森负面情况的采访只有马西斯夫妇的那份，而且他们只谈了邦联旗和三K党申请表。
A local activist, Ebony Davis, summed up the report this way-- "He was a great officer. He didn't do anything wrong but have memorabilia, and they fired him to keep us happy."
当地的一名活动家埃博尼·戴维斯这样总结这份报告：“他是个伟大的警察。他什么错事也没做，只是有了一些纪念品，他们解雇他只是为了让我们高兴。”
So how did we get to this, from a police chief who believes this officer has a problem with Black people to this mammoth report that doesn't say that at all? Chief Lewis' investigators handed him a report that comes to very different conclusions than he had. It's the report you'd issue if you wanted to keep Anderson on the streets.
那么我们是怎么走到这一步的呢？从一个认为安德森对黑人有偏见的警察局长，到这份根本没提这些的宏大报告？刘易斯局长的调查人员给他的报告得出的结论与他自己的结论大相径庭。如果你想让安德森继续留在岗位上，你才会发布这样的报告。
I never got an answer to why the report is just this laudatory stuff. I asked to talk to the people who did the investigation. The city said no. I asked Chief Lewis. Surprisingly, he told me he thought the report was critical. Honestly, it seemed like he hadn't read it in a while, and maybe he didn't remember.
我从来没有得到关于为什么这份报告全是溢美之词的答案。我要求采访调查组的人。市政府拒绝了。我问了刘易斯局长。令人惊讶的是，他告诉我他认为这份报告很尖锐。老实说，他看起来好像很久没读过这份报告了，也许他不记得了。
What the heck had happened inside Muskegon city government that could possibly connect those dots? The best answer I got is here, in Act 3, How to Fire a Police Officer.
马斯基根市政府内部到底发生了什么，能把这些点联系起来？我得到的最好答案在这里，第三幕，《如何解雇一名警察》。
OK, let's go back to that moment when Chief Lewis decided he wanted to fire Anderson. Not because of the official investigation-- he hadn't even seen that yet. He wanted to fire Anderson because of his own analysis. After he decided that, he met with the city's lawyers and they talked about how it would be tricky to fire Anderson. And it'd be tricky because of the reason Lewis wanted to get rid of him. It's hard to prove a police officer treats Black people differently and has a pattern of discriminating. They said, if Lewis tried to fire him for that, he really might fail.
好了，让我们回到刘易斯局长决定解雇安德森的那一刻。不是因为官方调查——他当时甚至还没看到报告。他决定解雇安德森是基于自己的分析。在他做出决定后，他与市里的律师开了会，商讨如何解雇安德森会很棘手。之所以棘手是因为刘易斯想除掉他的原因。要证明一名警察对待黑人不同且存在歧视模式是很难的。他们说，如果刘易斯试图以这个理由解雇他，很可能会失败。
Like, take the video of Anderson shoving the old woman. Anderson could argue it was justified, or maybe it was an accident. Take any of these incidents one by one, and he could say that there was some reason.
比如那段安德森推倒老妇人的视频。安德森可以辩解说是正当的，或者是意外。单独拿出这些事件中的任何一个，他都能说出某种理由。
Because there's always a defense. Mr. Anderson had a defense. Mr. Anderson had representation.
因为总有辩词。安德森先生有辩护，安德森先生有代表。
Chief Lewis says he called around to other police chiefs and police union officials.
刘易斯局长说他联系了其他警察局长和警察工会官员。
As I told you before, around the state, a lot of people went, you'll never sustain that. In the union world, I was told by a lot of people that, if my decision was to terminate, that it would not be sustained.
正如我之前告诉你的，在全州范围内，很多人都说，你不可能撑得住这个理由。在工会世界里，很多人告诉我，如果我的决定是解雇，那将无法维持。
That you wouldn't have grounds for termination?
也就是说你没有解雇的依据？
I would probably lose it later on down the road.
我以后可能会输得很惨。
And it happens. I mean, there's-- just since I've been here, I would say there's probably three different times people have been fired and awarded their jobs back.
这种情况确实发生过。我是说——就我在这里工作期间，我想大概发生过三次，有人被解雇后又被判复职。
Muskegon city manager, Frank Peterson. He was in these meetings with Chief Lewis and Muskegon's lawyers.
马斯基根城市经理弗兰克·彼得森。他和刘易斯局长及马斯基根的律师一起参加了这些会议。
And we just did not want that to happen in this case. Some of the cases, we're OK with it. But this one was, under no circumstance could we afford to have him be awarded his job back.
在这种情况下，我们绝对不想发生那种事。在某些案件中，我们可以接受，但这起案件，无论如何我们都不能让被解雇的人复职。
It's hard to fire a police officer. That's true pretty much everywhere in this country. As you probably know, police unions are powerful. They have lots of protections in their contracts.
解雇一名警察很难。这在全国大部分地区都是事实。你们可能也知道，警察工会势力强大。他们的合同里有很多保障措施。
And the instances where police officers do get fired for racism-- there have been a bunch of cases over the last couple of years, in Wilmington, North Carolina, Albany, New York, Warren, Michigan. And the thing is, in all those cases, police were not fired for mistreating people of color on the job. They were fired for things they said, because they write racist comments online, or they get caught on a recording saying explicitly racist things. There's a caught red-handedness to it.
而因种族歧视被解雇的警察案例——过去几年有好几起，在北卡罗来纳州的威尔明顿、纽约的奥尔巴尼、密歇根州的沃伦等地。但问题是，在所有这些案例中，警察并非因为在职时虐待有色人种而被解雇，而是因为他们说的话——比如在网上发表种族主义言论，或者被录音抓到发表明确的种族主义言论。有一种当场被抓的实锤感。
And the way those departments fired the officers was by arguing the racist comments violated the basic code of conduct for their jobs. Like, the code of ethics in Wilmington says, officers can't do things that reflect unfavorably on the Department or themselves. And Chief Lewis, after puzzling for a while over what legal argument he could use to fire Anderson, he had kind of an "aha" moment, and he kind of stumbled into a strategy like that, like the other cities used.
那些警局解雇警察的方式是辩称这些种族主义言论违反了工作基本准则。比如威尔明顿的道德准则规定，警察不得做出损害部门或自身声誉的行为。刘易斯局长在琢磨了很久可以用什么法律依据来解雇安德森后，有了一种“顿悟”，他无意中发现了一个策略，就像其他城市使用的一样。
In our policy procedures, one of the things you have to do is you, yourself, have to have the community trust in you. It's in our policy procedures. The community has to have some kind of trust in you to carry out your duties.
在我们的政策流程中，有一项规定是你必须获得社区的信任。就在我们的政策流程里。社区必须对你有某种程度的信任，你才能履行职责。
I looked it up and, indeed, this wasn't some technicality buried deep in department policy. It was right at the beginning. In the chief's preface that Lewis wrote himself, he refers to the public trust.
我查了一下，确实，这并不是埋在部门政策深处的技术性条文。它就在开头。在刘易斯亲自撰写的局长前言中，他就提到了公众信任。
When Lewis told me that this was his argument, that he was going to try to fire Anderson for losing the public's trust, I could not help but think, if this was the bar everywhere for every officer, a lot of officers would be fired tomorrow. Less than half of Americans say they have confidence in police these days.
当刘易斯告诉我这是他的论点——他打算以丧失公众信任为由解雇安德森时，我不禁在想，如果这就是各地考核每名警察的标准，那么明天一大批警察都会被解雇。如今，不到一半的美国人表示他们信任警察。
One benefit of this strategy was simplicity. All they had to prove was that Anderson had the stuff in his house and that people said he couldn't be trusted because of it. Lewis wouldn't have to argue all these individual incidents that the lawyers told him you might lose on.
这个策略的一个好处是简单。他们只需要证明安德森家里有那些东西，并且人们因此说他不值得信任。刘易斯不必辩驳律师告诉他可能会输掉的所有那些具体事件。
Another appealing thing about this plan-- it'd be fast. Lewis wanted to send a message by acting quickly. And in fact, from the day the Mathises posted, it was only five weeks until Anderson was fired. Amazingly quick for this kind of thing.
这个计划的另一个吸引人之处是速度。刘易斯想通过迅速行动来发出信号。事实上，从马西斯夫妇发帖那天起，到安德森被解雇仅用了五周时间。这对这种事情来说快得惊人。
But to make sure Anderson wouldn't fight them and try to get his job back, the chief did seem to give a few things away at the bargaining table. For starters, he didn't really fire Anderson. In actuality, Anderson signed a separation agreement.
但为了确保安德森不会反抗并试图复职，局长在谈判桌上确实做出了一些让步。首先，他并没有真正“解雇”安德森。实际上，安德森签署了一份离职协议。
He agreed to walk away voluntarily, not say anything bad about the city, not sue to keep his job. It was just going to be over. In exchange, the city would let him leave with his pension and retirement health care benefits after two decades on the job.
他同意自愿离开，不对城市发表任何负面言论，也不起诉以保留职位。一切就这样结束了。作为交换，城市允许他带着二十年的养老金和退休医疗福利离开。
This strategy for getting rid of a police officer is not unusual. A former police chief, named, Daniel Oates, wrote an article in The Washington Post where he said, in nine years running the department in Aurora, Colorado, he had 16 cops he wanted to fire. He only fired four of them. He was reversed on three of those. So with the other 12, he says, he, quote, "bent over backwards to negotiate their departures with creative severance packages." Not because he wanted to-- he felt he had no other choice.
这种清除警察的策略并不罕见。一位名叫丹尼尔·奥茨的前警察局长在《华盛顿邮报》上写文章说，他在科罗拉多州奥罗拉市管理警局的九年里，有 16 名想开除的警察。他只解雇了 4 名。其中 3 名被判复职。所以对于其他 12 名警察，他说他“竭尽全力协商他们的离职，提供有创意的遣散方案”。不是因为他想这么做，而是他感到别无选择。
In the negotiations between the city and Officer Anderson, the complaints about Anderson's history did come up, but it's kind of like a bargaining chip. Lewis told me he made it clear to Anderson and the union that the case for his termination was based on what was in his house and how he lost the public trust. They said if Anderson fought them, it could become about a lot more. It could become about Anderson's past and other things that he'd done.
在市政府和安德森警官的谈判中，关于安德森历史的投诉确实被提出来了，但这更像是一个筹码。刘易斯告诉我，他向安德森和工会明确表示，解雇案件的基础是他家里的东西以及他是如何丧失公众信任的。他们说，如果安德森反抗，事情可能会涉及更多。可能会涉及安德森的过去以及他做过的其他事情。
And so I was prepared to show this pattern. And I had other complaints that were in the hopper, that were coming forth, that I was going to inquire in those next. And the union knew it.
所以我准备好要展示这种模式。我还有其他投诉正排着队，陆续送来，我打算接着调查那些。工会也知道这一点。
Oh, if you win this one, this is coming next, then this could become next. And so that's why it was decided that we would just end this relationship, and he would move on.
哦，如果你赢了这一场，接下来还有，再接下来还有。所以决定还是终止这种关系，让他走人。
In other words, if Anderson took this deal, the city wouldn't dig into that stuff. Anderson could walk away without a real reckoning over his past. That's the best explanation I have for why the 421-page report is the way it is and why it doesn't really dig in to Anderson's mistreatment of people.
换句话说，如果安德森接受这个交易，市政府就不会深挖那些东西。安德森可以离开，而不用对其过去进行真正的清算。这就是为什么那份 421 页的报告会是那种样子，为什么它没有真正挖掘安德森虐待民众情况的最好解释。
I should mention, in his preface to the report, the chief promises more. He says there will be further investigation into additional complaints against Officer Anderson's behavior on the job, now that this part's done. That didn't happen though, and it's been two years. A Department spokesman told me there are no additional investigations into Anderson in the works.
我应该提到，局长在报告前言中承诺了更多。他说，现在这一部分完成了，将对安德森在职期间的其他行为投诉进行进一步调查。然而这并没有发生，已经过去两年了。一位部门发言人告诉我，目前没有针对安德森的其他调查在进行中。
Ben Calhoun. Coming up, the way that the city's deal with Officer Anderson affected the Mathises, who looked at that 421-page report and found something totally surprising about themselves in there. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
我是本·卡尔霍恩。接下来，市政府与安德森警官的交易如何影响了马西斯夫妇——他们看着那份 421 页的报告，在里面发现了关于他们自己完全令人惊讶的事情。稍后在芝加哥公共广播电台的节目中继续。
This is This American Life. I'm Ira Glass with our story about policing and Muskegon Michigan. Today's episode, A City Walks into an Investigation.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯，正在讲述我们关于密歇根州马斯基根市治安的故事。今天的节目是《城市卷入调查》。
So the police chief made a trade-off. He believed officer Anderson had a problem with Black people. He believed it completely affected the way he did his job. But he thought he couldn't fire him for it.
所以警察局长做了一个权衡。他相信安德森警官与黑人有问题。他完全相信这影响了他履行职责的方式。但他认为他不能以这个理由解雇他。
So he forced him out for, quote, "losing the public's trust" with that KKK application. And as part of the deal, the city's official 421-page report did not say anything negative about how Anderson treated Black people on his job. That trade-off-- Anderson had to leave, but he kept his pension. The city's official investigation portrayed him as an outstanding officer.
所以他强迫他以“丧失公众信任”为由离开，因为那个三K党申请表。作为交易的一部分，城市官方那份 421 页的报告没有对安德森如何在工作中对待黑人说任何负面评价。那个权衡——安德森必须离开，但他保留了养老金。城市的官方调查将他描绘成一名杰出的警察。
That trade-off had consequences for the people whose Facebook posts began all of this, the Mathises, and for others. Ben Calhoun picks up with Act 4, People who got the Short End of Anderson's Deal.
那个权衡对那些Facebook帖子的始作俑者——马西斯夫妇，以及其他人产生了后果。本·卡尔霍恩将从第四幕讲起，《那些在安德森的交易中受损的人》。
Best I can tell, the public at large just accepted what the city did. Anderson was gone. Maybe they grumbled that he got his pension. But fine, OK.
据我所知，广大公众只是接受了市政府的做法。安德森走了。也许有人抱怨他拿到了养老金。但好吧，没关系。
But it wasn't that way for Duke Stalling at all. Just to remind you of his experience with Officer Anderson, Anderson was called to his mom's birthday party because of a noise complaint and escalated things until he ended up pepper spraying a bunch of old people, and arresting Duke and one of his uncles. They filed complaints with the police department and tried to raise the alarm about Anderson, but nothing happened. No one ever reached out to hear their side of the story.
但这对于杜克·斯托林来说完全不是那回事。提醒一下他与安德森警官的经历：安德森因噪音投诉被叫到他母亲的生日派对，并将事态升级，最终对一群老人喷了胡椒喷雾，还逮捕了杜克和他的一位叔叔。他们向警察局提出了投诉，并试图拉响关于安德森的警报，但没有任何结果。没人联系过他们去听取他们的说法。
Years later, when the Mathises came forward about the stuff in Anderson's house, Duke thought, finally, everyone's going to see. But the way the city handled it, it didn't go that way because the city's report didn't talk about the pattern Anderson had with Black people.
多年后，当马西斯夫妇站出来讲述安德森家里的东西时，杜克想，终于，每个人都会看到了。但城市处理的方式，情况并没有那样发展，因为城市的报告没有谈到安德森对待黑人的模式。
What would it have meant to you if the police chief, as part of this process, would have said, essentially, yeah, this guy was a problem?
如果警察局长作为这个过程的一部分，从本质上说“是的，这个家伙是个问题”，这对你意味着什么？
Oh, everything. Oh, my hope was that they was going to look into my case. Again, hope, right? Innocence, naiveness.
哦，意味着一切。哦，我的希望是他们会调查我的案件。还是希望，对吧？天真，幼稚。
I hope that they reach out to me, hope they look into my case. I hope they look into the Julius case. I hope they look into all these cases and something really happens. And then they go to the families and make amends with these families that he terrorized. That was my hope.
我希望他们联系我，希望他们调查我的案件。我希望他们调查朱利叶斯的案件。我希望他们调查所有这些案件，并真的有什么结果。然后他们去找到这些家庭，与这些被他恐吓过的家庭和解。那是我的希望。
You were hoping that you were going to get a phone call.
你一直希望你会接到一个电话。
Oh, yeah, most definitely. I thought that's what an investigation is. You're going to look into every situation that he had an interaction with. But the investigation they said they was going to have, that was just to get us hopeful. Right? Get the people hopeful, so they can get rid of the anger. So our police can be on these streets without nobody want to do anything to our polices. We'll say everything we need to say to make them calm down. That's it. That's really all it's all about.
哦，是的，绝对。我以为这就是调查的含义。你会查看他参与过的每一个情况。但他们声称要进行的调查，那只是为了给我们希望。对吧？给人们希望，这样他们就能消除愤怒。这样我们的警察就能在这些街道上巡逻，而没人想对警察做什么。我们会说出一切需要说的话来让他们冷静下来。就是这样。这真的是整件事的全部意义。
It's a weird thing about this story. All that stuff that Chief Lewis said to me about how he was convinced that Officer Anderson had a problem with Black people and a pattern of incidents mistreating them, he's never said that publicly. Not in the report, not in comments to the press-- no city official has said anything like that. Not until now, this story.
关于这个故事有一件奇怪的事情。刘易斯局长告诉我关于他如何确信安德森警官与黑人有问题以及存在虐待他们的模式的所有那些话，他从未公开说过。不在报告里，也不在对媒体的评论中——没有城市官员说过类似的话。直到现在，这个故事。
So I was the one to break that to people like Duke Stalling.
所以我成了那个把真相告知像杜克·斯托林这样的人。
So I mean, that would have made me feel a whole lot better, if he would have said what he's saying to you, behind closed doors, in public about this officer. To hear that come from within, that you agreed and you felt the same way. You know, he's had a history of hurting or affecting a certain group of people, and we fired him and got rid of him because of that reason, you know? To let us know that we're on the same page here. I mean, that's how you build that trust with the community.
所以我的意思是，如果他在闭门会议上对你说的那些关于这位警官的话，能公开说出来，我会感觉好得多。听到内部发出的声音，你们同意并感觉是一样的。你知道，他有伤害或影响特定群体的历史，我们因为这个原因解雇并除掉了他，你知道？让我们知道我们在这件事上达成了共识。我是说，这就是你如何与社区建立信任。
When it came to the way that Anderson treated his family, Duke had always felt that race was a part of it, that he'd have acted differently if they were white. But it was a slippery part, and it was hard to prove, which happens all the time.
当谈到安德森对待他家人的方式时，杜克一直觉得种族是一个因素，如果他们是白人，他的行为会不同。但这是一个模糊的部分，很难证明，这种情况时有发生。
A person accused of racism can say, I don't have a racist bone in my body, or I'm the least racist person. And then all of a sudden, the conversation is this dead end. Everyone's just supposed to throw up their hands and be like, guess you can't prove what's in their heart.
一个被指控种族主义的人会说，我骨子里没有一点种族主义，或者我是最不种族主义的人。然后突然之间，对话就陷入了死胡同。每个人似乎只能摊摊手说，猜想你无法证明他们内心想什么。
It's within everything, yes. I've dealt with it in the real estate and offices and stuff like that. And I know it's a racial thing, but I couldn't take it to court and win because they never specifically say anything like that. Like, you really got to call somebody a [BLEEP]. You literally got to say these type of things in order-- I can treat you like a [BLEEP], but never call you a [BLEEP]. I can treat you like one, never call you that. You can't say that I'm racist. But you knew it was-- you knew it was-- you knew.
它存在于一切之中，是的。我在房地产和办公室里都处理过这些事。我知道这是种族问题，但我无法将其诉诸法庭并胜诉，因为他们从未具体说过那样的话。就像，你真的得叫某人是[哔—]。你实际上得说这些类型的话才能——我可以像对待[哔—]一样对待你，但从不叫你[哔—]。我可以像对待那种人一样对待你，但从不那样称呼你。你不能说我是种族主义者。但你知道它是——你知道它是——你心里清楚。
It's like a trap door. And 10 years earlier, Duke had watched Anderson slip through it. And when the city released their report, it was like he had to watch Anderson slip through it for a second time.
这就像一个陷阱门。10年前，杜克看着安德森溜过了它。当市政府发布报告时，就像他被迫第二次看着安德森溜过去一样。
I went back and I told Chief Lewis what Duke and others said to me, that if the city and Lewis saw a racial pattern of bad conduct and mistreatment by Officer Anderson, the city should have said it.
我回去告诉刘易斯局长杜克和其他人对我说了什么，如果市政府和刘易斯看到了安德森警官存在种族模式的恶劣行为和虐待行为，市政府就应该说出来。
Honestly, and I see where they're coming from. I get it. But when it came time for us to do the investigation, I felt I put everything in there to sustain this case and to get him to end his employment here.
老实说，我明白他们的意思。我懂。但当轮到我们进行调查时，我觉得我已经把所有东西都放进去了，足以支持这个案件，并让他结束在这里的雇佣关系。
To get the outcome that you felt was important for the city?
为了达成你认为对这个城市重要的结果？
And I can prove it today. I can look back and go, see? We did it right. But then again, somebody should say, it's not complete until the chief put the "racist" in there. You know, I guess we're going to live today to disagree. I didn't feel that was necessary. What I felt was necessary was in that report, and it worked for what I would call a correct outcome.
我今天可以证明这一点。我可以回头看并说，看吧？我们做对了。但话说回来，有人可能会说，除非局长把“种族主义者”写进去，否则它就不完整。你知道，我想我们今天只能保留意见。我觉得没有必要。我觉得必要的是在报告里的内容，这达成了我所称的正确结果。
But I guess the question that I'm asking is just, why not a public statement? They're sharing your take of, you know, there's a pattern of problems here. Why not a public statement saying, you guys are right, there was something wrong here?
但我猜我问的问题只是，为什么不发表公开声明？他们分享你的看法，你知道，这里有一种模式的问题。为什么不发表公开声明说，你们是对的，这里确实有问题？
Well I think, we did make a public statement of that. We went, you can't be an employee here. And matter of fact, you shouldn't be a police officer.
嗯，我想，我们确实发表过那样的公开声明。我们说，你不能在这里做雇员了。事实上，你不应该做警察。
We went around and around. Lewis was adamant. They made the right choice to get Anderson out.
我们兜兜转转。刘易斯很坚决。他们做出了除掉安德森的正确选择。
Act 5, No Good Deed Goes Unpunished.
第五幕，《没有好人得到好报》。
The people who were the most affected, directly affected by the city's decision never to publicly comment on how Anderson treated Black people, were the people who stuck their necks out and set this all in motion, Rob and Reyna Mathis. The Mathises were already being harassed. I laid out the details of that last time-- threats to their children, people in town shouting slurs at them, people stalking their house.
受市政府从未公开评论安德森如何对待黑人的决定影响最大的人，是那些挺身而出、启动这一切的人，罗伯和雷娜·马西斯。马西斯夫妇已经在被骚扰了。我上次详细列出了细节——对他们孩子的威胁，镇上的人向他们大喊种族歧视语，人们跟踪他们的房子。
But when the city put out its report, it made all that worse because of something surprising it said about them. It was something they didn't even know. And it was something that changed the way people in Muskegon saw them.
但当市政府发布报告时，情况变得更糟了，因为它说了一些关于他们的令人惊讶的事情。那是他们甚至不知道的事情。而且这改变了马斯基根的人们看待他们的方式。
Towards the end of the report, the Muskegon Police Department revealed that, that day when Rob and Reyna toured Officer Anderson's house, that was not actually the first time they crossed paths with him. In fact, over the years, they'd interacted with him a few times. Rob and Reyna found this out the day the city's report came out.
在报告的结尾，马斯基根警察局披露了，那天罗伯和雷娜参观安德森警官的房子时，实际上并不是他们第一次与他交集。事实上，多年来，他们已经与他有几次互动。罗伯和雷娜在城市报告发布的那天发现了这一点。
I believe we was in the car riding somewhere and somebody sent us the report or something like that. We went on a website or something and read it. And I was like, wow.
我相信我们当时在车里去某个地方，有人把报告发给了我们之类。我们上网看了一下。我当时心想，哇。
It was one of these incidents that caught everyone's attention, especially the Mathises. It was from 2008. Rob and Reyna totally remembered this thing, but they'd never put it together that it was Officer Anderson.
正是这些 incident 中的一个吸引了所有人的注意，特别是马西斯夫妇。这是 2008 年发生的。罗伯和雷娜完全记得这件事，但他们从没把这跟安德森警官联系起来。
In fact, both they and Anderson told investigators they didn't know each other. For the Mathises, this particular incident had just kind of mushed in with other interactions they'd had with police. They didn't remember a particular officer. It was just some random cop who treated them badly.
事实上，他们和安德森都告诉调查人员他们彼此不认识。对于马西斯夫妇来说，这个特定的 incident 只不过是他们与警察互动中的一个。他们不记得具体的警察。只是某个对待他们不好的警察。
I want to tell you the whole story because of the outlandish coincidence of this. If you remember, the reason Rob felt compelled to go public about the flags and the KKK application was because he imagined someday, somewhere, Officer Anderson would pull over a couple and things would get ugly. It turned out Rob and Reyna had been that couple a decade earlier.
我想告诉你整个故事，因为这巧合得离谱。如果你记得，罗伯觉得有必要公开关于旗帜和三K党申请表的原因，是因为他想象有一天，某个地方，安德森警官会拦住一对夫妇，事情会变得很糟糕。事实证明，罗伯和雷娜十年前就是那对夫妇。
It was the 4th of July in 2008. Rob and Reyna had grabbed a bite at Burger King, and they were on their way home. And Rob had to pee really bad, so he was going a little fast. But not that fast, even according to Officer Anderson, who says in his police report that he clocked them going between 31 and 38 in a 25, so like 10-ish over. Anderson pulled them over pretty much right at their house.
那是 2008 年的 7 月 4 日。罗伯和雷娜在汉堡王吃了点东西，在回家的路上。罗伯憋尿憋得很厉害，所以开得有点快。但并没有多快，甚至根据安德森警官的说法，他在警察报告中说测速显示他们是在 25 英里的限速区开到 31 到 38 英里之间，也就是超速 10 英里左右。安德森几乎是在他们家门口拦住了他们。
So he flicked the lights. And I pull up right at my side door.
所以他闪了灯。我在我侧门处停下。
We were literally right in front of our house. Literally, parked right in front of our house.
我们实际上就在房子前面。字面上，就停在我们房子前面。
Officer Anderson comes up to the car.
安德森警官走向车子。
He's like, what's your speed? I say, sir, I got to go to the bathroom. I just got to go to the bathroom so bad. He was, like, this is just going to take a second.
他问，你开多少码？我说，警官，我得去洗手间。我实在是憋坏了。他说，这只需要一秒钟。
So my wife was, like, he just got to go to the bathroom. So he's, like, shut up, ma'am. Blah, blah, blah.
我妻子说，他只是得去洗手间。他说，闭嘴，夫人。巴拉巴拉什么的。
Rob says he and Reyna were, like, "Shut up?" Officer Anderson went back to the car. Rob was in so much discomfort, he was afraid he was going to wet himself. After a few minutes, he got out, and he tried to signal to Officer Anderson to plead his case.
罗伯说他和雷娜当时心想，“闭嘴？”安德森警官回到了车里。罗伯感到非常难受，他担心会尿在裤子上。几分钟后，他下车试图向安德森警官说明情况。
I've had run-ins with different officers on occasion, and some of them be a little hard-ass sometimes. But I was being respectful. And I was, like, Officer, you can-- look, I'm pulling my shirt up. Like, you can search me. Here's my wallet. I'm pulling my pockets inside out. I'm raising my pants leg up, so he can see I ain't got no weapons.
我偶尔会和不同的警察有接触，其中一些人有时会表现得有点硬派。但我当时很有礼貌，我说，警官，你可以——看，我把衬衫掀起来。你可以搜身。这是我的钱包。我把口袋翻出来。我把裤腿挽起来，这样他能看到我没有武器。
I'm, like, you can call the dogs and search my car for drugs. I just gotta use the bathroom. I'm being totally honest with the guy, you know? And he's just, get in the car. Get your ass in the car. He cussing at us and stuff. So I'm like, man, this guy, man. I don't know what his problem is.
我说，你可以叫警犬来搜我的车查毒品。我只是得用洗手间。我对他很诚实，你知道吗？他只是说，回到车里去。滚回车里去。他冲我们骂骂咧咧。我心想，老兄，这个家伙到底怎么了。
So Rob gets back in. He's, like, OK, gotta hold it. He says 10 minutes go by, then 20.
所以罗伯回到车里。他心想，好吧，得忍住。他说过了 10 分钟，然后是 20 分钟。
Rob and Reyna's kids see the police lights, and so they come out to see what's happening. So now they're standing on the lawn. After a bit, neighbors come out, too.
罗伯和雷娜的孩子们看到了警灯，所以他们出来看发生了什么。现在他们站在草坪上。过了一会儿，邻居也出来了。
We sat there for like a half an hour. It don't take that long to run nobody's name. Sat there and sat there and sat there and sat there.
我们在那里坐了大概半小时。查某人的名字不需要那么久。坐在那里，坐在那里，坐在那里。
And steady, every time I go to open door to get out, get back in the car. Just a second. I'll be there in a second. Stay in the car. Stay in the car.
而且我每次去开车门想出来，他都要我滚回车里。就一秒钟。我马上就会处理的。呆在车里。呆在车里。
Rob, he was so desperate at this point, he gets out of the car and he's, like--
罗伯当时绝望到了极点，他从车里出来，说——
Look, man. I gotta go to the bathroom. I'm not going to sit here, a grown man, and urinate on myself because you won't let me go to the bathroom. I'm like, just search me. Search my car, whatever you got to do. I just gotta go to the bathroom. I'm not going to use the bathroom on myself.
听着，老兄。我得去洗手间。我不会坐在这里，一个成年男人，尿在自己身上，因为你不让我去洗手间。我说，搜我身吧。搜我的车，不管你要做什么。我只是得去洗手间。我不会尿在自己身上。
What did he say when you said that? Or how did he react?
当你那样说时他说了什么？或者他有什么反应？
He was, like, get your-- didn't I say get your motherfucking ass back in the car? Get in the car.
他像是说，滚——难道我没说让你滚回车里去吗？滚回车里。
At this point, Reyna got out of the car to talk to their kids. Officer Anderson turned his attention to her. When he did, he kind of gave up on Rob. And Rob was able to run inside to pee.
此时，雷娜下车和孩子们谈话。安德森警官转向她。当他这样做时，他不再理会罗伯。罗伯得以跑进屋里去小解。
Then Anderson walked over to Reyna.
然后安德森走到雷娜身边。
He told me to get my ass back in the car. And I was standing at the door. I wasn't all the way out of the car. I was, like-- the door was open, and I was standing there telling my kids that everything was going to be OK, or whatever.
他叫我滚回车里。我当时站在车门旁。我没有完全离开车子。我当时，门开着，我就站在那里告诉孩子们一切都会好的。
He was telling me to get my ass back in the car, and I'm telling him I'm talking to my kids. They're scared, or whatever. And I don't remember--
他叫我滚回车里，我告诉他我正在跟孩子们说话。他们很害怕什么的。我不记得——
Reyna said she was kind of pinned between the car and Anderson.
雷娜说她被夹在车和安德森之间。
And that's when he tried to put me in the headlock. And all I did was try to-- you know, like-- I didn't want him to, like-- however he did it, he did like this. And it busted my nose, or whatever, so my nose was bleeding.
就在那时他试图对我锁喉。我只是试图——你知道，像——我不希望他，像——无论他怎么做的，他就像这样。打伤了我的鼻子什么的，所以我的鼻子在流血。
But when I went back like this to protect myself, that's when he got hit.
但当我像这样向后退去保护自己时，他被打到了。
Reyna says she lifted up her arms to block Anderson, and her arm hit him. Rob, in the middle of this, comes back out of the house to find Reyna with a bloody face and Officer Anderson wrestling her to the ground. He starts to walk up, like, what's happening?
雷娜说她举起双臂挡住安德森，她的手臂撞到了他。罗伯此时从屋里出来，发现雷娜一脸是血，安德森警官正把她按在地上。他走过去，心想，发生了什么？
So when I was coming outside the gate, he said, stay there, stay there. So he put his hand on, like he was going to pull his gun out. So I'm standing. I'm like, Reyna, just be cool, be cool, be cool. And he grabbed her--
当我从门口出来时，他说，呆在那儿，呆在那儿。他把手放在那儿，就像要掏枪一样。所以我站在那。我说，雷娜，冷静点，冷静点。他抓住了她——
What were they saying? What were they saying when you came out of the house?
当你从屋里出来时，他们在说什么？
He was, like, you're resisting arrest. You're resisting arrest. She's like, my husband just had to go to the bathroom. And he said, I told you to stay in the car. I told you stay in the car. So he grabbed her, and he smashed her head down on the car. So he's wrestling around with her. She's trying to get away from him.
他说，你妨碍公务。你妨碍公务。她说，我丈夫只是得去洗手间。他说，我告诉过你呆在车里。我告诉过你呆在车里。所以他抓住她，把她的头重重地撞在车上。他和她扭打在一起。她试图摆脱他。
And you're having to stand there on the other side of the fence with your kids and watch this whole thing happen.
你不得不站在围栏另一边和你的孩子们一起看这发生的一切。
Watch the whole thing. I was worried that he's going to shoot her in front of me and the kids.
目睹了一切。我担心他会在我和孩子面前枪杀她。
Once Anderson had Reyna on the ground, he put handcuffs on both of her wrists, saying--
安德森把雷娜按在地上后，给她戴上手铐，说——
I told you to get your ass down. Now you're going to fucking jail. Stuff like that. And my kids were screaming at this point, so.
我告诉过你要滚下来。现在你要进监狱了。类似这样的话。我的孩子们此时都在尖叫。
Were you surprised that that happened all of a sudden?
你对突然发生的一切感到惊讶吗？
No. The way-- the aggression he had, I knew something was going to happen. So I wasn't surprised that it did happen. I was more mad because it happened in front of my kids, and they were terrified. Because they were younger then.
不。那种——他的攻击性，我知道会发生什么。所以我不惊讶。我更愤怒，因为它发生在我孩子面前，他们被吓坏了。因为他们当时还小。
Just to reiterate, the issue here, to start, was driving about 35 in a 25. Anderson's report from that night describes more or less the same course of events. The key difference is that Officer Anderson says Reyna didn't hit him inadvertently. He says she swung around and slapped him.
再次重申，这里的问题开始时只是在 25 英里限速区开到 35 英里。安德森当晚的报告描述了几乎相同的事情经过。关键区别在于安德森警官说雷娜不是无意撞到他的。他说她转过身打了他的耳光。
Reyna was charged with resisting and obstructing a police officer, a charge that carries potential prison time.
雷娜被控抵抗和妨碍警察，这项指控可能面临监狱刑期。
When my husband found out I was facing five years in prison, he said, no. He said, we're fighting this-- because they kept trying to make me take a deal.
当我丈夫发现我面临五年监禁时，他说，不。他说，我们要抗争到底——因为他们一直试图让我接受认罪协议。
He said, no, we're going to get a lawyer. We're going to fight this. He said, I want the dashboard cam as evidence, he said, because they'll see exactly what-- everybody will see what happened.
他说，不，我们要请律师。我们要抗争。他说，我想要行车记录仪作为证据，因为人们会看到究竟发生了什么——所有人都会看到。
The Mathises say their lawyer requested the dashcam footage from the stop. According to the Mathises, they were told the video could not be located. And then, suddenly, Reyna was offered a new, much-reduced plea deal. She decided she just wanted to be done with all this, and she took it.
马西斯夫妇说他们的律师要求提供拦截时的录像。据马西斯夫妇所说，他们被告知录像找不到。然后，突然，雷娜得到了一个新的、减轻很多的认罪协议。她决定只想结束这一切，所以她接受了。
The night of the traffic stop, back in 2008, Rob and Reyna did not think it was about race.
2008 年交通拦截的那个晚上，罗伯和雷娜并不认为这与种族有关。
I'm, like, A, he's just being a dick or he's had a hard night. Maybe the previous person maybe pulled over or something gave him a hard time, and he's just taking it out on everybody else, you know? He was on a power trip, you know?
我当时心想，A，他就是个混蛋，或者他那天过得很不顺。也许前一个人给了他一点麻烦，他只是发泄在别人身上，你知道吗？他在耍权力，你知道吗？
I have a badge. I'm in control. That's what I thought. I didn't think anything about him being racist. I just thought, yeah, he was a cop on a power trip.
我有徽章。我在掌控。那是我的想法。我没认为他是种族主义者。我只觉得，是的，他是个耍权力的警察。
I mean, I've seen Mexican cops do the same thing to Mexicans, and Black cops do the same thing to Blacks. It's just some of them have their power trips. So I just thought he was on a power trip.
我的意思是，我见过墨西哥警察对墨西哥人做同样的事，黑人警察对黑人做同样的事。他们中有些人就是爱耍权力的。所以我只是觉得他在耍权力。
That was how they saw it when it happened. But now, after seeing those things in Anderson's home a decade later, they both looked at it differently.
当事情发生时，他们就是那样看的。但现在，在十年后看到安德森家里的那些东西后，他们俩的看法不同了。
I don't think he would have did that with a white couple in the car. He would've been, like, OK, go use the bathroom, or I'm just going to let you off-- because he was just disrespectful.
我不认为他会那样对待一对白人夫妇。他会说，好的，去用洗手间，或者我只是放过你——因为他就是不尊重人。
In hindsight, looking at it, everything he did was a racist act.
回过头来看，他做的一切都是种族主义行为。
From when he first looked at us, he didn't have good intentions. The man is racist. And I know that now. But had I known it back then, probably been a lot different.
从他第一次看我们时，他就没存好心。那个人就是种族主义者。我现在知道了。但如果我当时就知道，可能会有很大不同。
So then I was pissed. I kind of-- kind of wish I would have probably assaulted him before he assaulted me. And that's the truth.
那时候我非常愤怒。我有点——甚至希望在他袭击我之前我先袭击了他。这是真心话。
If the city, specifically Chief Lewis, would have said publicly some version of what he actually thought about Officer Anderson, that he had a pattern of being overly aggressive, escalating situations, especially with people who weren't white, then-- I think-- when people found out about this traffic stop, they might have seen it in that light.
如果市政府，特别是刘易斯局长，公开说出他对自己对安德森警官看法的一些版本，比如他确实有过度攻击、升级冲突的倾向，特别是对非白人——那么——我想——当人们发现这次交通拦截时，他们可能会以那种眼光看待它。
But without that context, Anderson's version is the one people believed. It's Anderson's account in that 421-page report the city issued. He stopped Rob and Reyna. Reyna got out of hand. She assaulted him.
但没有那种语境，人们相信的是安德森的版本。那就是城市发布的那份 421 页报告中安德森的陈述。他拦截了罗伯和雷娜。雷娜失控了。她袭击了他。
Because of that, this revelation that they'd had this run-in with Officer Anderson years earlier, it really did change how lots of people saw the Mathises.
因为这个，关于他们几年前与安德森警官有过冲突的披露，确实改变了许多人看待马西斯夫妇的方式。
That's when more threats came in. Then people were saying, oh, yeah, you're out for Officer Anderson because he put your wife in jail, because of this, because of that. Then they was like, oh, you're not just the good guy because you outed Officer Anderson for having the Confederate flag and the Klan application. It's because we were holding a grudge against a police officer.
那正是更多威胁进来的时候。人们说，噢，是的，你针对安德森警官是因为他把你妻子送进监狱了，因为这个那个。然后他们说，噢，你并不是什么好人，仅仅是因为你揭发了安德森有邦联旗和三K党申请表。那是因为你们在对一名警察怀恨在心。
Of course, Rob and Reyna hadn't sought out Anderson's house on some vendetta. The realtor sent them the listing. But this version of the story took hold.
当然，罗伯和雷娜并没有带着什么报复心理去搜寻安德森的家。是房产经纪人发给他们那个房源的。但这个版本的故事占据了上风。
That's what's still out there. That report that City Hall put out, it's me and my wife had a problem with him, and we went after him.
现在外面流传的就是这个版本。市政府发布的那份报告，说是我和我妻子对他有意见，然后我们去搞他。
When we were talking, I told Rob what Chief Lewis said to me, that Anderson had a pattern of behavior and a problem with Black people. Just like with Duke Stalling, Robert had no clue. No clue Lewis felt that way. No clue Lewis saw the same things in Anderson that he did.
当我们交谈时，我告诉罗伯刘易斯局长对我说了什么，说安德森有行为模式，与黑人有问题。就像对杜克·斯托林一样，罗伯毫无头绪。完全不知道刘易斯有那样的感觉。不知道刘易斯在安德森身上看到了他所看到的同样东西。
And the fact the city left that out, it made Rob mad.
而城市遗漏这一点，让罗伯非常愤怒。
Why wouldn't he say that in the report in the beginning? It would have changed everything. Everything. Me and my wife wouldn't be looked at as some liars, that we went after him. You sitting up here creating this falseness. And it's just wrong. Tell the truth.
为什么他一开始不在报告里说出来？那会改变一切。一切。我和我妻子就不会被看作是撒谎的人，说是我们去搞他。你坐在这里编造这种虚假。这完全是错的。说真话。
Now the police chief wants to tell the truth, but the matter is done. But truthfully, the information that you just got from Chief Lewis, if that would have been put in the report, then they would have said, Mathises, you all did a great job. Thank you.
现在警察局长想说真话了，但事情已经结束了。但老实说，你从刘易斯局长那里得到的那些信息，如果当时写进报告，那么人们会说，马西斯夫妇，你们做得太好了。谢谢。
The way the Mathises see it, even if the chief removed Anderson for betraying the public's trust, even if the reason for the firing wasn't the way he treated Black people, the city could have removed Anderson without also giving him a clean bill of health. They could have said, we've looked into this. We're troubled by the way he treats people. It was not OK. We don't want officers acting the way that he did.
在马西斯夫妇看来，即使局长因为安德森背叛公众信任而免职他，即使解雇理由不是他对待黑人的方式，城市也可以在不给予他健康证明的情况下除掉安德森。他们本可以说，我们调查过了。我们对他的待人方式感到不安。那是不对的。我们不希望警察像他那样行事。
Act 6, Was It Worth it?
第六幕，《这值得吗？》
It's hard for Rob and Reyna to calculate the ways this changed their lives. The risk they took was a single act, a single moment. But the impact of it is still happening even a couple of years later. The costs for them are still adding up.
罗伯和雷娜很难计算这如何改变了他们的生活。他们冒的险是一个单一的行为，一个单一的时刻。但它的影响即使在几年后仍在发生。对他们的代价仍在不断累积。
Some of what all this has cost the Mathises are things that have ended up in no report, no investigation, official or unofficial-- the harassment, the threats, the conspiracy theory now floating around out there that Rob and Reyna were out to "get" Officer Anderson. The last time I saw Rob, I asked him how he looks back on all of it, given the results.
马西斯夫妇所付出的一些代价在任何报告、任何调查（正式或非正式）中都没有体现——骚扰、威胁、现在流传着的关于罗伯和雷娜去“搞”安德森警官的阴谋论。我最后一次见到罗伯时，我问他鉴于这些结果，他是怎么回顾这一切的。
I'm just glad that he ain't riding around on the streets, and he's not harassing no more minorities, and nobody ain't going to get killed by Officer Anderson. And it'd be a justified shooting, because he can make up what he want to, because he killed a person.
我只是很高兴他不再在街上巡逻，不再骚扰少数族裔，也没有人会再被安德森警官杀害。那会是一次正当的枪击，因为他可以编造任何他想要的，因为他杀了一个人。
So do you feel like it was worth it?
所以你觉得这值得吗？
Oh, man. I feel like I, me and my wife, saved lives by doing what we did.
老兄。我觉得我，我和我妻子，通过我们的所作所为拯救了生命。
Reyna didn't disagree. She was glad Anderson lost his job-- really, pretty fast. That doesn't always happen. But the practical costs, she couldn't help but look at those, too.
雷娜并没有不同意。她很高兴安德森失去了工作——事实上，相当快。那并不总是会发生。但现实的代价，她也禁不住去关注。
And then, with all the backlash, all the negative stuff, it just made me second guess what we did. I felt like I did something wrong. Maybe we shouldn't have did it. Maybe we should have just kept our mouth shut. But at the end of the day, who is to say that he wouldn't still be working and another young, Black man gets killed?
然后，伴随着所有的回击，所有的负面东西，这只是让我重新考虑我们做过的事。我觉得我做错了什么。也许我们不该那样做。也许我们应该闭嘴。但归根结底，谁能说如果他不还在工作，另一个年轻的黑人男子就不会被杀呢？
Or there's another Reyna, who goes to prison for five years because he says that she assaulted him and-- you know. I'm so conflicted because, one minute, I'm like, we did do the right thing. We did do the right thing. But then when you go through everything that we've been going through, it's kinda hard. Like, maybe we shouldn't have, though.
或者会有另一个雷娜，因为他说她袭击了他而坐五年牢——你知道。我非常矛盾，因为有一分钟，我心想，我们确实做了正确的事。我们确实做了正确的事。但当你经历所有我们一直在经历的事情时，这很难。就像，也许我们不该做，虽然。
Rob and Reyna did what they did out of concern for other people's safety, but they ended up sacrificing their own. They used to feel like the police were out there to protect them, to help them. And now, on any given day, they worry that they're not. Here's Reyna.
罗伯和雷娜做他们所做的事是出于对他人安全的担忧，但他们最终牺牲了自己的安全。他们过去觉得警察是为了保护他们、帮助他们而存在的。而现在，在任何一天，他们都担心警察不会那样做。有请雷娜。
I promise you, every day I leave this house when I drive to work, I pray to God that I don't get pulled over, because I'm scared. I'm legal. I have a license. I have insurance. And I'm scared.
我向你保证，我每天离开这房子去工作时，我都向上帝祈祷不要被拦下，因为我很害怕。我是合法的。我有驾照。我有保险。但我害怕。
I make Rob drive me to work a lot. And it's hard on him, because he has to wake up to come and get me at 5:00 in the morning, you know, and then take my daughter to school, and do this and do that. But my anxiety gets so bad, I don't want to drive, because I'm scared I'm going to get pulled over. And anything can happen.
我让罗伯经常开车送我去工作。这对他是种负担，因为他得在清晨 5 点起床来接我，你知道，然后还要送我女儿去学校，做这做那。但我的焦虑太严重了，我不想开车，因为我害怕被拦下。任何事情都可能发生。
And it might be somebody who knew him or--
那可能是某个认识他的人或者——
Right. Or one of his friends.
对。或者他的朋友之一。
Those worries and fears, they tell me, they aren't just when they leave the house. They've seeped in. The last thing I'll play for you is from Reyna. This was from five months after the city had terminated Anderson, when most of the people in Muskegon had stopped thinking about all this.
那些担忧和恐惧，他们告诉我，不仅仅是在离开房子时才会有。它们已经渗透进来了。最后播放给你们听的是雷娜的话。这是在市政府解雇安德森五个月后，当时马斯基根的大多数人已经停止思考这一切了。
I probably get two or three hours sleep, here and there. Once we started getting the threats-- I had a lot of bad dreams. I couldn't sleep. I would have to-- I used to put a chair right by that window, and just sit out and look out the window in the dark, just so I could see.
我大概只能睡两三个小时，断断续续的。一旦我们开始收到威胁——我做了很多噩梦。我无法入睡。我不得不——我曾经把椅子放在窗边，坐在那儿看着窗外的黑暗，只是为了能看到。
Just to keep an eye on what was going on?
只是为了留意正在发生的事情？
Yes. And then we have a monitor with our security cameras, and I would lay it in my bed with me. And I would just hold it and watch it for hours, because it shows all of our cameras, all six. So I'd watch all the little screens, for hours. I couldn't sleep, and that's what I would do.
是的。我们有个监控，连着我们的安全摄像头，我把它放在床上。我只是抱着它看了几个小时，因为它显示了我们所有的摄像头，全部 6 个。所以我看着所有的小屏幕，看了几个小时。我无法入睡，这就是我会做的。
And how long did that last?
那持续了多久？
I still do it sometimes. I don't sit there no more. But I will sit here, or I will lay in my bed, and I'll hold the monitor right in my hand and just watch it.
我现在有时候还会做。我不再坐在那里了。但我会坐在那儿，或者躺在床上，把监视器拿在手里看着它。
Even now?
现在还在？
Sometimes, yeah. Or I sit on the stairs, right there, the fourth stair. So I can see right out at night when my porch light is on. So I sit there.
有时候，是的。或者我就坐在楼梯上，就在那儿，第四个台阶上。所以我晚上 porch 灯亮着的时候能看出去。所以我坐在那儿。
I texted Rob the other day. He told me they still get threats sometimes, and they still watch the monitors regularly. "That's the norm now," he wrote. "We're always on guard."
前几天我给罗伯发了条短信。他告诉我他们有时还会收到威胁，他们仍然会定期查看监视器。“这现在成了常态，”他写道。“我们总是保持警惕。”
OK, one last thing before we go today. Over the last six months, as Ben Calhoun has been working on this story, he and I have talked a lot. And the thing that I have wondered about, myself, about this whole thing, this whole time, was, OK, if you had a police officer with a history like Officer Anderson's, all these interactions with civilians that go badly over 21 years, why did it take this freak event-- people spotting a KKK application on a wall-- before anybody looked at his record the way the chief did and did something about him?
好了，今天结束前还有最后一件事。在过去六个月里，当本·卡尔霍恩一直在研究这个故事时，他和我就此讨论了很多。而我一直好奇的事情，关于整个这件事，这一整个时间，是，OK，如果你有一个有着安德森警官那样记录的警察，21 年里所有那些与平民的互动都搞得很糟糕，为什么直到这件怪事发生——人们在墙上发现一张三K党申请表——才有人像局长那样审视他的记录并采取行动？
Couldn't they have fired him sooner? Across the country, where we see these incidents where police are mistreating people, it just seems like, if there were some system to catch problem officers, it can make a difference. Does any police department try, in a real way, in an effective way, to do that, flag them, deal with them?
他们不能早点解雇他吗？在全国各地，当我们看到这些警察虐待民众的事件时，似乎，如果有一些机制来抓获问题警察，它就能产生影响。有哪个警察部门在以一种真实的方式，以一种有效的方式尝试那样做，标记他们，处理他们吗？
Hello there, Ben.
你好，本。
Hi.
嗨。
So I was not alone in this question, you also were kind of obsessed with this.
所以我并不是唯一有这个问题的人，你也沉迷于此。
Yeah. I put this question, this exact question, to several policing experts. And eventually, one of them told me about these things called "early warning systems." And basically what these are are computer programs that track problematic incidents in an officer's career, and they flag an officer if there's too many of them. And one of these experts told me that, if Muskegon had one of these systems, then all of this would have been different.
是的。我把这个问题，完全这个问题，提给了几位治安专家。最终，其中一位告诉了我关于这些被称为“早期预警系统”的东西。基本上，这些是跟踪警察职业生涯中问题事件的计算机程序，如果事件太多，它们就会标记一名警察。其中一位专家告诉我，如果马斯基根有这些系统之一，那么这一切都会不同。
Oh.
哦。
Yeah, right? But then I checked, and Muskegon does have one of these systems in place.
是的，对吧？但我查了一下，马斯基根确实有这样的系统。
Oh, it does?
哦，有吗？
It does. But it, you know, didn't lead to any action against Officer Anderson.
有的。但是，你知道，它并没有导致对安德森警官采取任何行动。
OK, then what's the problem?
OK，那问题出在哪？
Well, I mean, it turns out that a lot of these systems are just really bad. And there's a few reasons for it. One of them is that some of the systems-- this includes Muskegon's-- they rely really heavily on police officers reporting each other, which doesn't happen very often. It relies on citizen complaints, which we just know that people don't complain about police officers very often, because they worry that nothing's going to be done--
嗯，我是说，结果是这些系统很多都很糟糕。有几个原因。一个是其中一些系统——包括马斯基根的——它们非常依赖警察互相举报，这并不经常发生。它依赖于公民投诉，我们知道人们并不经常投诉警察，因为他们担心什么都不会做——
Which is true, often, right?
这通常是事实，对吧？
Yeah, totally true. Another reason they're bad is that, when these systems get installed, they have to be negotiated with police unions. And police unions kind of defang them. And the last reason, it turns out they might be measuring just the wrong things.
是的，完全正确。它们糟糕的另一个原因是，当这些系统安装时，它们必须与警察工会谈判。而警察工会有点拔掉了它们的牙齿。最后一个原因，事实证明它们衡量的东西可能完全错了。
Huh.
哈。
So a few years ago, a group at the University of Chicago got together and they wanted to change the way this works. Basically, they wanted to "moneyball" the whole situation. They wanted to break down all the things police do on the job into numbers and statistics. And then they wanted to find the stats that best predict bad behavior.
所以几年前，芝加哥大学的一个小组聚在一起，他们想改变这一切的工作方式。基本上，他们想用“魔球理论”来处理整个情况。他们想把警察在职期间做的所有事情拆解成数字和统计数据。然后他们想找到最能预测不良行为的统计数据。
So give me an example of what these moneyball stats would be.
那么给我一个这些“魔球统计数据”的例子。
OK. So one example-- they say the old systems would measure just the sheer number of times a police officer would use force. So if they wrestle somebody to the ground, or if they tase somebody. And what they want instead, they say it tells you just way more if you measure something they call "proportionality of force."
OK。所以一个例子——他们说旧系统只会衡量一名警察使用武力的次数。所以如果他们把某人摔倒在地，或者他们电击某人。而他们想要的是，他们说如果你衡量他们所谓的“武力比例”，它会告诉你更多。
And what that is is how much force is a police officer using, given the situation that they're in? Are they using force in a situation that wouldn't usually call for it? So we can, like, think of Officer Anderson going into the backyard and ending up pepper spraying a bunch of unarmed people.
这就是警察在他们所处的情况下使用了多少武力？他们是在通常不需要使用武力的情况下使用武力吗？所以我们可以，比如，想想安德森警官进入后院，最终对一群手无寸铁的人喷胡椒喷雾。
Over a noise complaint.
因为噪音投诉。
Or shoving that old woman to the ground. That's using a lot of force, where force isn't necessarily needed.
或者把那个老妇人推倒在地。那是使用了大量武力，而在那种情况下武力并不一定是必要的。
Right, exactly. So I talked to a policing expert named Ron Huberman. He's a former Chicago Police officer, and he's one of the people trying to get people to use these new moneyball-type stats. He told me the University of Chicago group crunched the numbers for a lot of officers, and they were looking at whether they were using force in situations that wouldn't usually call for it.
对，完全正确。所以我采访了一位名叫罗恩·胡伯曼的治安专家。他是前芝加哥警察，是试图让人使用这些新“魔球”统计数据的人之一。他告诉我，芝加哥大学小组为很多警察计算了数据，他们正在观察他们是否在通常不需要武力的情况下使用武力。
You learn two things. You learn that most police are great at de-escalation, and you learn that some police are always trying to use as much force as they lawfully can, or the policy enables them to, right? They're at the top end of that spectrum.
你会学到两件事。你会学到大多数警察都擅长降温，你会学到一些警察总是试图在法律允许或政策允许的范围内使用尽可能多的武力，对吧？他们处于那个光谱的最顶端。
Those officers are much more likely to have a major adverse event occur, right? Something terrible, the nature of what you can turn on and see on TV here and there, right?
那些警察更有可能发生重大的负面事件，对吧？一些可怕的事情，就是你在电视上到处都能看到的那种本质，对吧？
Tell me another one. What else do they track?
再给我讲一个。他们还跟踪什么？
So another thing that these folks are looking at is something called "discretionary arrest." So that's essentially, an officer goes into a situation that doesn't necessarily require an arrest and makes one. Say, pulling over the Mathises for going 35 in a 25, that results in an arrest. Or--
所以这些人正在关注的另一件事被称为“自由裁量逮捕”。这本质上是，一名警察进入一个不一定需要逮捕的情况并进行了逮捕。比如，拦下因为限速 25 开到 35 的马西斯夫妇，导致了逮捕。或者——
So it's just a traffic stop. It's a speeding ticket, shouldn't necessarily result in an arrest.
所以这只是一个交通拦截。这是超速罚单，不一定会导致逮捕。
Yeah, exactly. Same with Duke Stalling, right? It's a noise complaint, and he ends up arresting Duke and his uncle.
对，完全正确。杜克·斯托林的情况也是一样，对吧？这是一个噪音投诉，而他最终逮捕了杜克和他的叔叔。
OK. So all that goes into an algorithm or whatever.
OK。所以所有这些都进入了一个算法什么的。
Yeah, exactly. And one of the most interesting things that these people are finding is that patterns of problematic behavior with police officers typically go together. So if an officer has one kind of bad behavior, then they're probably going to have others.
对，完全正确。这些人发现的最有趣的事情之一是，警察的问题行为模式通常是共同存在的。所以如果一名警察有一种不良行为，那么他很可能也有其他不良行为。
So the officer who pushes down an old lady is more likely to be an officer who's involved in, say, three shootings. And they're also more likely to be the officer who is at a traffic stop telling a couple to shut up.
所以那个推倒老太太的警察更有可能是一名卷入，比方说，三起枪击案的警察。他也更有可能是在交通拦截时叫一对夫妇闭嘴的那个警察。
We don't generally find that, oh, an officer is just rude, or an officer just uses a little too much force. And if we use this story that you shared, this officer wasn't just rude, right?
我们通常不会发现，噢，一个警察只是粗鲁，或者一个警察只是使用了稍微多一点的武力。如果我们使用你分享的这个故事，这个警察不仅仅是粗鲁，对吧？
That is the general accurate story. We don't really just find, well, this officer is otherwise great, but is just aggressive and disrespectful, right? What the data would generally show is, that officer is going to be struggling in other parts of their job. They're using more force than one would expect. They're using a higher proportionality of force.
这是普遍准确的故事。我们实际上并没有发现，嗯，这个警察在其他方面很棒，只是咄咄逼人且不尊重人，对吧？数据通常显示的是，该警察在他工作的其他部分也会挣扎。他们比人们预期的使用更多的武力。他们使用了更高比例的武力。
I just want to add, another thing that they're tracking is who police officers are doing problematic things to. So if an officer uses more force with people of color, say, that's going to show up.
我只是想补充一点，他们追踪的另一件事是警察对谁做出了有问题的事情。所以如果一名警察对有色人种使用了更多的武力，比方说，那就会显示出来。
So does this moneyball system work better? What do we know? Do they actually catch more problem officers and get them to change, or get rid of them?
那么这个魔球系统效果更好吗？我们知道什么？他们真的抓到了更多的问题警察并让他们改变，或者除掉他们吗？
I mean, what Ron Huberman says is they've only been doing this for a few years, so it's still pretty early to tell how it's working. But he says some departments get better results than others. And the key variable is how they follow through, like when an officer gets flagged.
我是说，罗恩·胡伯曼所说的是他们只做了几年，所以很难说它效果如何。但他确实说一些部门的结果比其他部门好。关键变量是当一名警察被标记后他们如何跟进。
Are a lot of departments actually using the new moneyball versions of the stats?
很多部门真的在使用这些新魔球版本的统计数据吗？
No, not that many. Ron Huberman's company, which is based on all this University of Chicago research, is called Benchmark Analytics. And that one is working with about 150 policing agencies-- which, I know, sounds like a lot at first. But yeah, there's like 18,000 policing agencies all over the country.
不，没那么多。罗恩·胡伯曼的公司，基于所有这些芝加哥大学的研究，名为 Benchmark Analytics。它与大约 150 个治安机构合作——我知道，一开始听起来很多。但是的，全国有大约 18,000 个治安机构。
Most of America is Muskegon, right? That is the average or the normal police department in America, which is, there might be something in place. But fundamentally, it does not have both the data and the sophistication to identify problematic patterns.
美国大部分地区都是马斯基根，对吧？那是美国平均或正常的警察部门，也就是，也许有一些机制，但从根本上说，它既没有数据也没有成熟度来识别有问题的模式。
So I asked Ron Huberman, what are the big obstacles for getting these systems up and running? And he said some of them are super straightforward. It's like money and tech and getting that in place.
所以我问罗恩·胡伯曼，建立这些系统的最大障碍是什么？他说其中一些非常直截了当。就像钱和技术以及把那个落实到位。
But the big problem, he said, is politics. Police unions, they just typically fight anything that involves scrutinizing and disciplining officers. So to get these systems in, that's where the resistance is going to be.
但他说是大问题是政治。警察工会，它们通常会反对任何涉及审查和纪律警察的事情。所以要把这些系统引入，那里就是阻力所在。
Well, Ben, thank you very much.
好吧，本，非常感谢你。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Well, the program was produced today by Ben Calhoun and me, with help from Dana Chivvis and Zoe Chace. Original music for today's episode by Matt McGinley. People who put together today's program include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Chris Benderev, Susan Burton, Sean Cole, Michal Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Damien Graf, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Will Peischel, Alix Spiegel, Robyn Semien, Laura Starecheski, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
好吧，今天的节目是由本·卡尔霍恩和我制作的，得到了达娜·奇维斯和佐伊·蔡斯的帮助。今天节目的原创音乐由马特·麦金利创作。参与今天节目制作的人员包括比姆·阿德温米、埃尔纳·贝克、克里斯·本德雷夫、苏珊·伯顿、肖恩·科尔、米哈尔·科米特、阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、达米安·格拉夫、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、赛斯·林德、托宾·洛、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、威尔·佩舍尔、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、罗宾·塞米恩、劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。我们的主编是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的资深编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是埃马纽埃尔·贝里。
Special thanks today to Eric Hood, Pastor Duane Bennett, Mayor Stephen Gowron, Destinee Keener-Sargent, Jenn White, Alex Kotlowitz, Dustin Dwyer, Paul Butler, Sharon Fairley, Craig Futterman, Tracey Meares, Timothy Maat, and the Muskegon police officers who spoke to us on background for this story. Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes. And what's it going to cost you? Nothing. It's absolutely free. Also, there's videos, there's lists of recommended shows to listen to. Tons of other stuff there. Again, ThisAmericanLife.org.
今天特别感谢埃里克·胡德、杜安·本内特牧师、斯蒂芬·高隆市长、德斯蒂尼·基纳-萨金特、詹·怀特、亚历克斯·科特洛维茨、达斯汀·德怀尔、保罗·巴特勒、莎伦·费尔利、克雷格·富特曼、特雷西·米尔斯、蒂莫西·马特，以及在此次报道中向我们提供背景信息的马斯基根警察。我们的网站 ThisAmericanLife.org，你可以在那里流媒体播放我们超过 750 集的档案。这要花你多少钱？零。绝对免费。此外，还有视频，有推荐收听的节目列表。上面还有大量其他东西。再次强调，ThisAmericanLife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. We were playing a pickup game, basketball, earlier this week. And he tripped me. Everybody saw it, but he would not admit it.
《美国生活》由 PRX，即公共广播交流中心交付给公共广播电台。和往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。本周早些时候我们在打一场篮球赛。他绊倒了我。所有人都看到了，但他就是不承认。
I don't remember ever throwing down a grandmother.
我不记得我的职业生涯中曾经把哪位祖母推倒在地。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。